the federal reserve is expected to raise
short-term interest rates this afternoon
to fight the highest inflation in 40
years you've all felt it a recent cbs
news poll found that 66 percent of
americans say inflation is difficult or
it's a hardship the chief investment
strategist at bank of america warned
just last month that the inflation shock
is worsening the rate shock is just
beginning and a recession could be
coming oh no bank of america ceo and
chairman brian moynihan joins us to
discuss
perfect day to have you mr moynihan at
the table
so would it be good news if they raise
it for most americans if the rates are
raised as expected because most people
hear that and they go no no no please no
and you say what well that that's that's
the tension of it but the real question
is why is the fed raising rates and
that's because of trying to tame
inflation inflation is worse than a
higher rate structure we found that out
through various periods of time so
that's what you have to pay attention to
sort of when rates are going up why when
they went up in you know 17 18 19 was
because the economy was strong we'd
fully recover from the financial crisis
they're going up now because frankly the
impact the pandemic even though
individuals are still struggling and
things are going on in general the
economy is as big as it was before the
pandemic it's expected to grow at a
faster rate and now they have to take
what they call monetary accommodation
out of the system to normalize economy
and bring down inflation risk because if
they don't bring it down they don't
become really problems so one of your
top people though said that a recession
is coming you agree well i've got a lot
of economists and i always say to
congress but i'm talking about your top
people yeah it it risk the debate here
is can they get it right right this is a
tricky execution the employment market
is so tight as the fed makes this action
you know it's a hard landing a soft
landing a bouncy landing and lots of
words around it and that's the big
debate so our economists are more
worried that a hard landing is higher
probability it was last year but i would
tell you at any given time i've ever
asked the congress the probability
recession next 12 months is like 20 so
it's not zero ever and and so yes we
have to be careful and that's that's
what the fed's trying to get right how
do i guide this back to normal after all
that stimulus stuff or all that activity
after the recovery
and then they're against two big factors
one is people are spending money today
at the fastest rate they've spent in a
good while so in april our spending was
up you have 20 percent type of levels
now you got to normalize that low for
taxes say 15 would be a fair number
that's april and that's higher than
march that was higher than february and
so people are still spending money
travel
getting out and doing things maybe not
on home repair like stuff
they that spending is good news wait so
average american who's experiencing
hardship right we've got all these polls
uh it sounds like you're saying in the
short term that hardship is going to
deepen because you're going to still
have inflation and the rates are going
to go up so if they're paying a home
mortgage or a car loan that could go up
as well well the people have a mortgage
actually had a great benefit so this
will only affect new mortgages and that
that's a certain amount so the issues
affect housing prices and they'll try to
bring the housing market back in housing
prices rising at 20 percent a year is
not good for the people trying to buy
short-term pain for the average american
is going to continue in the next three
to six months and and that's one of the
tricky executions it'll be hard for
americans who are paying more for goods
and services and we got the impact of
the war and the food crisis and stuff
and food prices but on the other hand
the wages are going up fast and that's
the other thing the fed's trying to deal
with which is the employment markets as
tight as it's ever been honestly and so
that's the balance the fed's trying to
get right which is to bring those back
in line if they keep spiraling we get
into something we got into that we
you're not old enough but i'm old enough
to have remember the days when the rate
structure went up in the teens because
they couldn't get it under control so
right now we're not in that condition
the unemployment's good people are
spending money that's all good tailwinds
they have more money in their accounts
the customers in april their account
balances grew a bank of america again
people with 2 000 5000 average balance
are
carrying 13 000 accounts before the
pandemic they're carrying like 3 500 so
there's a lot of cash that's all good
news the question is can can this all
happen softly and that's the debate so
yes higher prices but if a higher wages
offset them but if i get that spiral
just keep going that's not good i would
like to hear your thoughts on something
has been a topical conversation over the
last couple of days the supreme court is
reportedly planning to overturn roe v
wade
there have been
reports that major employers including
citigroup
that they are going to cover travel
expenses for women that want to get
abortions in other states
will uh bank of america be doing the
same
with all things like this we look at
what our team needs from us so first of
all the decision has to come down and
the leak and everything that you guys
have been covering is is tragic in a
sense but when the case comes down we
have a group of teammates who'll sit
there with our hr teammates in a broader
group they'll sit and say what do we
need to do for our team so the positions
we take on this and other matters is
drill as a company has to be over what
our team needs in reaction i could have
a personal view point of view but that's
not my that's not what we do we go into
it and have a view of what the team
wants so give us a few weeks you'll give
us the case has to come out and give us
a reaction and we'll figure out what we
do but
this you know this is a tough issue for
our team we have 200 000 people
represent all of america for the country
yeah it's a tough issue and so we'll see
let's let us go to work on let it play
out for going to work for sure but you
said a few years ago uh that the role of
a ceo is now driving or includes driving
what you think is right
on this issue before the supreme court
of uh access to an abortion has a
constitutional right do you think it is
correct that women should have that
access or not we look it's a settled law
of the land we believe that people
should have that access the question
there is going to be there's going to be
a lot of discussion about what this case
says it means but let's go back to when
we said took a position on guns a few
years ago
what happened is a team came to me and
said look
four of the nine victims in charleston
were related to teammates two people two
of our teammates were in las vegas four
people in the post nightclub and i went
down to orlando and talked to him a
couple days after one of them was of
emt from the military had been in
afghanistan and war said this is the
worst thing he's ever seen stated
they said we have to do something about
the high impact right had nothing to do
with the second amendment nothing to do
with the right to hunt nothing and so we
took that position because our team said
we're doing we took the position about
you know the so-called bathroom bill in
north carolina because our team wouldn't
come to meetings because they said they
didn't feel safe well brian you better
notice
that that makes decisions that are
beyond business decisions
so if if your employees and your
customers take a stand is that what
guides your decision-making process on
these issues and we have a lot of people
a lot at stands but the question is can
our people be effective can they serve
our customers well can they do the
things and that's how we take it so we
believe we have four constituents to run
our company we believe profits and
purpose the fourth constituent's
communities it's i put in my new report
letter and that's how we run it and we
deliver for the shareholder and we
deliver for society so it's not like we
go out and find issues to talk about
it's those issues are important to our
communities because in a day a bank
reflects its communities so what's
keeping you up at night brian listen for
most people it's gas prices what's
keeping you up at night look we have
there you go the big issues are still
we have a pandemic to finish getting
through and every day i have teammates
that get this disease and the great news
is that
the impact is so much lower the vaccines
were wonderful the science embedded in
that the work done is unbelievable right
so that's one the russian ukraine award
is a backup and create a recession in
europe around the world you know that's
more of an economic question uh and then
you know then the usual parade of
interesting things cyber security and
all those types of things that you have
to worry about but
what i also have to worry about is to i
have the team to serve you as a customer
and a great team and that goes back to
how we think about these issues and we
have a group of people who have varying
points of view honestly right right left
everything who argued out come in we say
we got to do this and that's how we get
it sounds like you're watching the way
we're watching yeah thank you brian
sleep tight yes all right thank you very
much appreciate you being here